[Music]  and a big defense of the tunnel I oh boy  it'll be cousins and he's going hard for  the whole here's where you're taking the  ball to the basket I'm looking for a  foul call not worried about anything  else and put the ball in the basket but  no one wants to get in the world  lines up and closed with authority  so the pelicans down down at 30% what  o'clock tomorrow scuzz ins up top that's  it that's a really good recovery bin to  matumbo no no no  cousins  just takes over favors and just says  thank you don't even try to get this one  cousins gets a touch help out Wow Jam  don't Marcus cousins nearly brought down  the backboard and rim Jameer pull-up  three and funky hammer sit on the run  pictures worth a thousand words when  that picture is moving it's got to be  worth more  [Applause]  now watches coast-to-coast  [Music]  [Applause]  now this is the cousin ATAR with the  major finish they son come and they said  no no no don't come my way  [Music]